we thought you know it's such a good
thing to let people know about somebody
who they're getting curious about and
this week everyone's curious about this
matt gates guy so we thought
what better time to do matt gates 24
things you don't know about me
for example uh my favorite dating app is
venmo
i recently sponsored a bill to name a
post office after charlie sheen
that's indicative i'm the first member
of congress to send my press releases
with axe body spray
i'd say billy eilish is hot i guess if
you're into older chicks
i've been to over 200 proms
[Applause]
i've been to both traffic school and sex
traffic school
wow i think all those republicans who
talk about me behind my back need
to man up and tweet it from a fake
account with a bogus name
my go-to pickup line is do you come here
often or does your mom just drop you off
in the morning
you